what have you found out about why the
ketogenic diet helps mental disorders
when I did a deep dive into the science
of mitochondria that's when my mind was
blown the mitochondria play a role in
neurotransmitters hormone production and
regulation Kern inflammation both on and
off and play a direct role in immune
system function and then you ask basic
Common Sense questions like well what
would happen if mitochondria weren't
functioning properly mental diagnoses
also have physical problems like
autoimmune disorders the Common Thread
among all of them is metabolism and more
specifically mitochondria and once you
understand that we can start
implementing treatments that will heal
people like the ketogenic diet